>> Will Sentance: Đi thôi.
Hãy xem điều đó vì nó sẽ là một đường phức tạp.
Nhưng bắt đầu với dòng đầu tiên của chúng tôi ở đây, chúng tôi muốn tiếp tục một thời gian, Ryan.
Tôi xin lỗi Ryan.
Ryan, chúng ta đang làm gì ở đây trong dòng mã của chúng ta?
>> Ryan: Khai báo hiển thị hàm.
>> Will Sentance: Khai báo một hàm hiển thị, chính xác và
lưu trữ nó trong bộ nhớ chung.
Nó ở đó, hiển thị chức năng được lưu trữ.
Tuyệt vời, cảm ơn bạn, Ryan.
Dòng hai, bên tay trái.
Ethan, chúng ta làm gì ở phía bên trái đây,
chỉ một chút dễ dàng ở đây đầu tiên Ethan.
>> Ethan: Khai báo một dữ liệu tương lai không đổi.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác, dữ liệu trong tương lai, tôi không bao giờ biết liệu người Mỹ nói dữ liệu hay
dữ liệu.
Nhưng được rồi, bây giờ nó chưa được khởi tạo.
Nhân tiện, điều này cho chúng ta biết rằng cuộc gọi tìm nạp ở phía bên phải,
chức năng mặt tiền kích hoạt nội dung trong nền,
nó cũng phải làm điều gì đó trong JavaScript.
Bởi vì kết quả của nó trong JavaScript tại thời điểm đó
được lưu trữ ở phía bên tay trái.
Vì vậy, nó phải là hai hướng về một mặt nào đó, hai hệ quả.
Vì vậy, dữ liệu trong tương lai.
>> Will Sentance: Đây rồi, futureData sẽ là kết quả trong JavaScript
của một nửa hậu quả của việc tìm nạp, bảng điều khiển JavaScript của nó.
Hãy nhớ rằng, đầu ra của phía bên phải được lưu trữ ở phía bên trái.
Nhưng đây là một hàm JavaScript giả vờ, nó là một mặt tiền.
Nó sẽ thực hiện một số công việc JavaScript cho chúng ta, nhưng nó cũng tự động
nhưng nó cũng sẽ thực hiện một số công việc trong nền, trình duyệt web.
Đây rồi, đến URL của chúng tôi.
Vì vậy, hãy làm điều đó với hệ quả JavaScript trước.
Nó sẽ ngay lập tức trả về trong JavaScript.
Hãy để tôi sử dụng màu hồng của tôi ở đây cho đối tượng đặc biệt của tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Vật đặc biệt của tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Một đối tượng hứa hẹn,
nó chỉ là một đối tượng được tạo tự động trong JavaScript bằng cách tìm nạp.
Nó có hai thuộc tính.
Chúng ta sẽ xem những gì họ làm sau này.
Giá trị không được xác định, không có gì được lưu trữ trên đó.
Có thể bạn đang nghĩ, chờ chút, tôi sẽ lấy lại một số dữ liệu.
Tôi tự hỏi nơi đó có lẽ sẽ hiển thị trở lại trong JavaScript.
Và một thuộc tính được gọi là đã hoàn thành.
Nó sẽ trở thành ẩn nhưng cực kỳ quan trọng, đó là một mảng trống.
Và đối tượng đó sẽ được lưu trữ nếu đầu ra của phía bên phải được lưu trữ trên
bên tay trái và bị rách rất nhiều, nó sẽ được cất giữ ở đâu?
>> Người nói 4: Trong tương laiData.
>> Will Sentance: Trong nhãn futureData, chính xác là trong mã định danh futureData.
Chúng tôi lấy nó, chúng tôi gắn nó vào, >> Will Sentance: FutureData,
đây rồi, giá trị, tôi có thể nghe thấy Tana đang lo lắng về cách
Tôi đã đi đến đây với đối tượng lời hứa của tôi ở đây.
Nào, chúng ta bắt đầu,
trên được hoàn thành là một mảng lớn, trống.
Nó đây, dân gian.
Thật tốt,
nhìn này, tôi chuẩn bị thiết lập một số công cụ trình duyệt web nền.
Tôi có quên tôi đã thiết lập nó không?
À, tất nhiên là không, tôi có một vật hứa hẹn nhỏ đáng yêu ở đây khiến tôi nhớ
mà tôi đã thiết lập một cái gì đó trong nền.
Nhưng bây giờ, mọi thứ trở nên thú vị.
Đâu là hệ quả khác của tìm nạp trên bảng đối với
chuyên gia về vị trí không gian- >> Ethan: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Ethan, của chúng ta ở đâu
khác- không, không, không,
bạn không cần phải- đâu là hệ quả khác của việc tìm nạp trên bảng?
>> Ethan: Nó nằm trong trình duyệt web.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác là nó nằm trong trình duyệt web.
Nhìn này, hai cái ngạnh, [SOUND], phải không?
Và hệ quả khác là ở trình duyệt web.
>> Will Sentance: Đây rồi.
Trong trình duyệt web, nó ở đó, nơi chúng tôi sẽ thiết lập,
bây giờ đôi khi tôi gọi XHR này là yêu cầu HTTP XML, xuất phát từ khái niệm
của XML là định dạng của dữ liệu mà chúng tôi gửi thông điệp qua Internet.
HTTP là tập hợp các quy tắc về cách chúng tôi gửi tin nhắn giữa trình duyệt và
một máy chủ, một giao thức HTTP.
Và yêu cầu ý nghĩa, tôi muốn nhận được thứ.
Nhưng chúng ta sẽ chỉ nói về nó một cách tổng quát hơn với tư cách là một mạng,
có nghĩa là qua Internet, yêu cầu.
Đây rồi, một Yêu cầu Mạng.
Đó là tính năng chúng tôi sẽ sử dụng trong trình duyệt web ở đây.
Đây rồi, Yêu cầu mạng, >> Di chúc: Đây rồi.
Và tôi đoán chúng tôi đang làm điều này với khoảng không mili giây.
Chúng tôi có xu hướng bắt đầu từ đó.
Nhân tiện, hãy nhìn xem từ năm chữ cái đó đã làm được bao nhiêu.
Và chúng tôi, vẫn chưa xong.
Một yêu cầu mạng tới Twitter cần biết thông tin quan trọng nào Jeff,
từ những gì đang được chuyển vào tìm nạp,
những thông tin quan trọng mà nó cần biết để biết đi đâu?
>> Jeff: Địa chỉ.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng và đó là hai phần ở đây.
Nó có tên miền,
điều đó sẽ cho chúng tôi biết máy tính nào trên Internet để truy cập, tại địa chỉ IP nào.
Và một khi chúng ta hạ cánh ở đó, con đường, sẽ cho chúng ta biết phần nào của máy tính đó
lưu trữ dữ liệu, tuyến đường mà chúng tôi sẽ đi và lấy dữ liệu từ đó.
Hai phần đó sẽ được chuyển đến Yêu cầu mạng của chúng tôi ở đây.
Vì vậy, chúng ta phải có twitter.com của chúng ta,
và chúng ta sẽ có con đường của mình.
Và chúng tôi có thể gửi dữ liệu từ một trình duyệt qua Internet hoặc chúng tôi cũng có thể yêu cầu dữ liệu.
Vì vậy, chúng ta có thể nói, này, tôi có một tweet mới mà tôi muốn bạn lưu.
Phương pháp chúng tôi sử dụng cho điều đó là gì?
Phương thức HTTP mà chúng tôi sử dụng để gửi dữ liệu, để đăng là gì.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: OK.
Kính thưa.
Được rồi, mọi người.
[LAUGH] Tuyệt vời, vâng, đăng, làm tốt lắm.
Chính xác, đăng.
Còn khi chúng ta muốn chủ yếu là nhận được các tweet dữ liệu?
Được rồi, phải- >> Khán giả: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Điều này thật ngớ ngẩn.
Được rồi.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi sẽ quay lại điều đó.
Nếu tôi muốn lấy dữ liệu thì sao?
>> Người nói 4: Nhận.
>> Will Sentance: Nhận.
>> Ryan: Nhận.
>> Will Sentance: Làm tốt lắm, mọi người.
Để nó trong.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy,
chúng tôi đã không chỉ định điều đó ở đây.
Đó là vì mặc định tìm nạp để lấy.
Nó sẽ mặc định có được.
Nếu chúng tôi muốn Đăng, chúng tôi thực sự có thể chuyển sang như một đối số khác
để tìm nạp một đối tượng có đầy đủ các tùy chọn.
Điều đó có nghĩa là loại thông tin bổ sung về cách chúng tôi muốn sử dụng tìm nạp.
Và chúng ta có thể thiết lập phương thức để đăng.
Nhưng chúng tôi sẽ mặc định nhận được tất cả từ năm chữ cái này,
loại điên rồ.
Đó là tính năng chúng tôi đang sử dụng.
Nó đã hoàn thành chưa?
Vâng, đó là tất cả các loại thứ hai, nhưng
khi hoàn thành, >> Will Sentance: Chúng ta sẽ làm gì?
Nó có hoàn thành ở 0 mili giây không?
Mất bao lâu để có thể truy cập Internet?
Có mất không mili giây để có thể truy cập Internet không?
Không, vậy nó đã hoàn thành chưa, Kayla?
>> Kayla: Không. >> Will Sentance: Chắc chắn là không.
Tại chỗ trên.
>> Will Sentance: Trên thực tế, trước khi chúng tôi chuyển sang những gì chúng tôi làm khi hoàn thành,
bắt đầu thôi.
Hãy bắt đầu công việc.
Vì vậy, nó sẽ gửi một tin nhắn đến qua Internet,
nó bắt đầu gửi một thông điệp HTTP qua Internet đến trụ sở của Twitter.
Họ đây, Twitter HQ, nó đây.
Tôi không bao giờ biết liệu tôi đang vẽ một máy tính ở đây hay giống như một văn phòng, nhưng
hãy để nó mơ hồ.
Thực ra đó là, >> Will Sentance: Có thể
một văn phòng, phải không?
Có thể là, nó khá thú vị.
>> Khán giả: [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Một quan sát,
đó, qua Internet, bắt đầu bằng 0 mili giây,
tắt nó chạy nói, này, Twitter, tôi cần đi và lấy dữ liệu.
Được rồi, nhưng nó chưa hoàn chỉnh vào thời điểm này.
Nhân tiện, tất cả điều này được thực hiện bởi năm chữ cái này.
>> Will Sentance: Tôi sẽ quay lại câu chuyện của tôi về
người sử dụng lao động tại tuyến đường sắt xuyên biển.
Tất cả trên Internet, làm thế nào về điều đó?
Được rồi, vì vậy, tại Internet, vâng, vì vậy,
khi hoàn thành, điều gì sẽ xảy ra?
Nếu bạn còn nhớ khi tôi nói thời gian chờ, khi chúng ta thiết lập một tính năng nền,
chúng tôi đã có một chức năng ở đây, nó sẽ tự động chạy trên Call Stack,
hãy thực sự đặt Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi vào đây vào thời điểm này,
sẽ tự động chạy trên Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, >> Sẽ gửi: Bật
hoàn thành nhiệm vụ nền.
Nhưng có ai thấy một hàm được phân tích cú pháp để tìm nạp ở đây không?
Không, vì vậy hai tính năng chính của chúng tôi hoặc
các chức năng mặt tiền cho các tính năng của trình duyệt web, chúng có một mô hình khác.
Họ nói, thay vì có một hàm được truyền vào,
bạn đã có một vật thể đẹp đẽ này đang theo dõi
thực tế là chúng tôi thiết lập một cái gì đó trong nền.
Vì vậy, một người sẽ sử dụng nó.
Và trên thực tế, khi dữ liệu đó quay trở lại, hãy sử dụng màu tím cho dữ liệu trả về của tôi từ
Twitter, khi nó hoàn thành, nó sẽ trở lại với một số tweet.
Họ gọi nó là đối tượng phản hồi.
Chúng tôi sẽ đơn giản hóa nó và
chỉ cần cung cấp cho nó chuỗi tweet, bất cứ khi nào nó quay lại.
Điều đó có thể đi đâu?
Hãy giơ tay nếu bạn có ý tưởng
làm thế nào chúng tôi có thể đưa dữ liệu đó trở lại các công việc mà nó có thể quay trở lại trong JavaScript.
Vâng, hãy có Kayla.
>> Kayla: Tôi không nhớ bạn đã gọi nó là gì,
trên, một cái gì đó trên >> Câu di chúc: Nó không phải
vào mảng đó.
Mark, bạn có muốn viết tắt cái này không?
>> Đánh dấu: Vào giá trị?
>> Will Sentance: Vào tài sản giá trị.
Nhân tiện, bạn đã nói, Kayla, ở đó, vào tài sản giá trị.
Bởi vì fetch có hai ngạnh này và chúng được kết nối mật thiết với nhau.
Như vậy khi nhiệm vụ nền hoàn thành,
nó sẽ dính vào đối tượng trả về ngay lập tức đó.
Bất cứ khi nào điều này xảy ra, có thể là ngày mai, yêu cầu mạng rất, rất chậm.
Nhưng có thể là bất cứ lúc nào,
đối tượng đó đã được lưu trữ vào futureData có một chút đẹp đẽ, nhìn vào
đó, thuộc tính ràng buộc không xác định trống rỗng, cái gì có thể được lưu trữ Kayla?
>> Kayla: Câu trả lời.
>> Will Sentance: Dữ liệu phản hồi, dữ liệu lấy lại từ Twitter,
cô ấy đúng chỗ.
Nó sẽ trở lại thuộc tính giá trị này.
Đặc biệt, Matt,
Loại vị trí chính xác mà tôi có thể đặt nó trong bit khi hoàn thành ở đây là gì?
>> Matt: Đó là trong tương laiData.
>> Will Sentance: FutureData, mm-hm, futureData.,
>> Matt: Giá trị dấu chấm.
>> Will Sentance: Giá trị chấm, chính xác là như vậy,
futureData.value sẽ được cập nhật dữ liệu,
như Kayla đã nói, từ việc nói với Internet.
Vâng, cô ấy đã đúng chỗ, cảm ơn Matt.
Được rồi, mọi người, chúng ta có thể nói một chút về những gì năm chữ cái đó đã làm được không?
Chúa ơi, họ thiết lập ở chế độ nền, họ nói chuyện với Internet
với tất cả thông tin cần thiết và lấy lại dữ liệu phù hợp.
Nhưng họ cũng thiết lập trong JavaScript một đối tượng giữ chỗ nhỏ được gọi là
một đối tượng hứa hẹn.
Chỉ là một đối tượng thông thường nhưng với một số thuộc tính tự động được tích hợp sẵn.
Và điều đó đã được lưu trữ vào futureData, nó đây.
Nó có một thuộc tính giá trị trống, nó có một mảng trống trên thuộc tính đã hoàn thành,
mà theo cách này, chúng tôi sẽ xem như một thuộc tính ẩn.
Nhưng nó được liên kết mật thiết với công việc nền đang được thực hiện.
Như vậy khi công việc nền kết thúc,
có thể là 200 mili giây kể từ bây giờ, 300, ai biết được?
Thuộc tính giá trị đó của đối tượng sẽ được cập nhật [SOUND].